>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Daniel Wertz: All
right, well thank you all
for coming here today
to our panel discussion
on Primary Source for
Research on North Korea.
This is organized with the
help of the Library of Congress
as a part of my organization,
The National Committee
on North Korea's knowing North
Korea workshop for our students
and young professionals.
And we're very excited to
have a really great panel
for today talking about the
diverse sources that exists
for doing primary source
research on North Korea.
Speaking first will be Sonya
Lee who will discuss the Library
of Congress' collection of
North Korean publications.
Sonya is a career
reference specialist
at the Scholarly Service Section
of the Asian Division here
at the Library of Congress.
She graduated from the
University of California,
Los Angeles with the Master
of Information Science degree
and has worked at the Library
of Congress since 1995.
As the recommending office
of the Korean Collection
of the Asian Division,
Lee has helped
to build the Korean Collection
of approximately 300,000 volumes
of monographs and over 7,600
periodical titles as of today,
including 281 serial
titles from North Korea.
Lee has been especially
concerned
with increasing the
research content
of North Korean materials
as well
as making the collections
available
through cataloging and outreach.
In 2018 this year, she
completed a long-term project,
the North Korean Serial
Index and Database
which improve access to North
Korea serials and items.
The North Korean serials index
and database lets researchers
and scholars study North
Korea in unusually depth.
And up next will be Eric Van
Slander of the National Archives
in reference administration.
Eric is reference archivist
in the textual reference
services division
at the National Archives
in College Park Maryland
where he specializes in
records related to World War II,
the Allied occupations of Japan
and South Korean
and the Korean War.
Mr. Van Slander has worked
at the National Archives
in various capacities
since 2001.
He has bachelors and masters
of art degrees in history
from the City University
of New York City College,
a master of library science
degree from the University
of College Park and he's
currently pursuing a doctor
of liberal studies degree
at Georgetown University.
And James Person
who'll be speaking
about the translated
diplomatic documents available
from North Korea's former
allies and the Eastern Bloc
and former Soviet Union is a
professor of Korean studies
at the John Hopkins School of
Advance International Studies.
Before join SAIS in 2017, he
served as the Founding Director
of Hyundai Motor-Korea
Foundation Center
for Korean History
and Public Policy
at the Woodrow Wilson
Center for scholars.
Between 2007 and early 2016,
he was the founding Coordinator
of the Wilson Center's
North Korea International
Documentation Project where
he oversaw the development
of a database featuring
tens of thousands
of declassified documents
from the archives
of North Korea's
former communist allies.
Between 2013 and early 2017,
he was also Deputy Director
of the History and Public Policy
Program at the Wilson Center.
Person holds a PhD in
modern Korean history
from the George Washington
University.
He was also holds an
[inaudible] in History
from Moscow State University and
a BA in history and fine arts
from the George Washington
University.
Person's presently
completing the book
that explores the transformation
of North Korea's political
and ideological system
between 1953 and 1967.
And before we start
with the panel,
I'd like to introduce
Qi Qui whose head
of the Scholarly Services
Section of the Asian Division
at the Library Congress for
some introductory remarks.
So thank you.
Qui.
[ Applause ]
>> Qi Qui: Thank you Daniel.
I'm just here to welcome
everyone to the Library
of Congress for this on
behalf of the Asian Division.
It's our pleasure to co-host
this panel presentation
with our national committee
on North Korea as part
of the workshop on
North Korean research.
If you are familiar
with the Library
of Congress Asian materials,
you probably know that here
at the Library, the
Asian Reading Room is
where you can find abundant
North Korean materials.
And here is just a
glimpse of what we have
in our rich collection.
But if you are not familiar
with our resources, no worries,
that's pretty much why
you are here, right?
Our specialist, Sonya Lee
will give you an introduction
in just a few minutes.
So beyond Korean materials,
users can also access
about four million
physical items
in over 130 vernacular languages
in the Asian Reading Room.
The Asian Reading Room is
just located in the other side
of the building also
on the first floor.
It-- In addition to physical
items, we also offer access
to digital materials and users
can get research assistant
from our special
subject specialist.
These materials include
most subject fields
and cover a geographic
area ranging
from the South Asian
subcontinent
and Southeast Asia to East Asia.
So if you have any questions
on using our collections
or Reading Rooms, please feel
free to talk to me or talk
to any of our librarians today
or check out our website.
And now probably you will
not have time to come
to our Reading Room
after this event today.
But I hope in the near future
you will be able to come
to the library and the
Asian Reading Room soon.
So, so, Sonya.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Sonya Lee: Good afternoon.
Welcome. My name is Sonya
Lee, reference specialist
at the Korean Collection,
Library of Congress.
Once a North Korean
scholar told me
that I will notice Korean
materials is like a playground.
And today my job is to help
you to figure out how to search
around in their playground.
And I'll share with you the
North Korean research materials
at the Library of
Congress and help you
to figure out how to use it.
But before talk-- oops sorry.
Before start talking about
Koran Collection, let me start
with the brief summary
of the Korean Collection.
1950, Library start to collect
the Korean Material during the
Korean War then the Korean unit
was only location among the
United State government collect
the material about Korea.
So any recast relate
to Korea send
to the Korean Unit thus
they make a collection
equally developed.
1955, the libraries start to
use inventory in South Korea
to systematically and
regularly acquired
of contemporary publication.
1966, is the important year
for the Korean Collection.
The United States and South
Korean government signed an
exchanged agreement in
which the Library start
to acquire the government
publication in different topic
which makes the collection
give-- has been.
Sorry, has become one
of the most significant
to strength the Korean
Collection.
Now, our collection
is most extensive
and comprehensive collection
outside of East Asia.
The Library has extensive
collections
which include a variety
of materials such as more
than 10,000 items
and 281 serials
and newspaper from North Korea.
Let's get to the main
part of the presentation,
North Korean Collection.
The Library contains one of the
largest North Koreas materials
in the world especially the
one disappeared during the
Korean War.
The North Korean materials at
the Library are one of a kind
which may not be available even
in North Korea, these makes--
this collection is extremely
rare and significant.
Also the Library provides the
researchers greater access
to old and new North
Korean materials freely.
Because of these reasons,
there's a high demand
from researchers for
access to this materials.
When I start working
at the Library,
I thought it will
be straightforward
to serve the users with
the North Korean materials,
but soon I had realized it was
anything but straightforward.
It was quite complex.
So for years since
I start working
at the Korean Collection, I
have worked on a few data basis
in order to render better
service to our users
which include the
Korea Serial Database
and North Korean Serial
Indexing Database.
First Korean Serial Database,
Korean Serial Database
is a friendly powerful
reference tool.
It provides the researchers
detailed information
about reaching diverse serials
at the Korean Collection.
It all start with
the warning query.
[Inaudible] Korean
Serials list please have
to receive the same
[inaudible] few times.
I knew I had to do
something about it.
Then we use those 10:26 file
like this image to
serve the users.
It was impossible to
respond to the recast.
So we pull all the Korean
serials at the Library.
Over 7,000 titles and then we
developed the Korean Serial
Database by reviewing each
title, assign a country code
and add a subject by the LC--
phone number and titles
in Korean characters.
Let's look at one example
why Korean Serial Database is
powerful reference tool.
Chollima this is a frequently
used North Korean serial.
Probably, you know the title.
When you put into record,
LC Subjects heading is
Korea North Periodicals.
As you can see, it
is not talking
about [inaudible] subject.
This is only say this is
periodical from North Korea.
Korean serial database
enable researchers
to start using All Field, Korean
field-- Korean title and Title,
Issuing Body, Publisher,
and Newspaper
and the Subject Heading
which are the value
to searching the database.
By using Advanced Search,
you can limit the search
to both Koreas or just
North Korea or South Korea.
Let's just search serials
and technology published
just from South Korea.
We retrieved the
total 175 result.
And from this list,
let's click one title
to get to those short lists.
From short list by
clicking the LCCN number
which is Library
Congress Control Number,
you can get to the full record.
When you have a full
record, always make sure go
to the bottom to get our
full coding information.
And now you can get all
North Korean serials list
with just one click
on the browse option
because if you remember
we review
and assign the country
code for each serial title.
Let's move to the next
part of the presentation.
Briefly, I like to
talk about how
to search the books
from North Korea.
The Library of Congress
cataloging record contains
approximately 17 million record
representing books and serials
for cartographic materials,
manuscript so forth.
It include also 3.2
million records
from our all-year database.
This record mostly books and
procedures and catalogued
between 1898 and 1980.
We called this record
as a PREMARC record.
Searching the PREMARC record is
much more complex which means
when you search the books
published before 1980 can be
challenging including
North Korean materials.
Let's see one example.
[ Foreign Language ]
How do you search this
book from North Korea?
Let's check its record first.
This was the original record
which was PREMARC record
when I found it accidentally.
I could not see any
country code.
There was not much publication
information besides--
published 1975, and then pnjil.
Definitely there was a typo.
I wonder what was pnjil.
So I went to those
tags locatable
and manually modified
this record by adding Kn
for North Korea and then
correct the typo pnjil,
it was ponjil, P-O-N-J-I-L.
And then add a publication
information
from the book published
in Pyongyang,
Sahoe Kwahak Chulpansa,
and changed the whole
theme information
from General Collection
to Asian Collection.
Modify record manually, modify
the PREMARC record manually
since that's the only
option we have now.
These are some of the common
issues of a PREMARC record.
Many of them doesn't
have a country code
or no publication
information, not much subject
and wrong holding
information and wrong spelling
and then inconsistent
with the spacing practice.
So when you're searching
for the North Korean book
from the Library of
Congress Online Catalog,
we recommend use these tips to
make a search more efficient.
First, use advanced search
and enter your search term
such as a subject and
leave a Boolean operator &,
and then put the Pyongyang as
the publication information.
This is very important.
Let's see how it works.
So we like to retrieve
North Korean book
on politics and government.
Sorry, I have erased
all that already.
And then enter North Korea
as a publication information
because we like to get
a North Korean book
so it's natural, right?
Natural reaction, but actually
this is a common mistake
that user do.
So when we did this search, we
retrieved all these 13 results
which include those three
films from North Korea,
two films from Japan, four
books from South Korea,
four books from Washington,
D.C. We could not find any book
from North Korea
from this search.
So at this time, we typed
the politics and government
as a subject and then Pyongyang
as a publication information.
From this search, we
retrieved 275 record
and then we found the book,
books record we are looking for.
So [foreign language].
So please make sure
add a Pyongyang
as a publication information.
Lastly, North Korea Serial
Indexing Project, NKSIP.
The Asian Division at the
Library of Congress has ruled
out North Korean serial
database online indexing tool.
The database offers researchers
enhanced access to periodicals
and articles published
from North Korea.
Currently, there are
34,000 article index
in 21 North Korean serials.
They are now searchable
for the first time.
In the past, there were
no indexing resources
at the article level for the
North Korean serials anywhere
in the world.
So without specific
bibliographic information,
user has to browse
numerous titles and issues
to find a specific
issues, articles they want.
Access to index to
this historical
and cultural material offers
insight into the policy,
economy, political,
social, history, military,
legal and financial
and government issues
that affect the contemporary
foreign policy
and strategy related
to North Korea.
We start this project
with the following goals,
to fill the article level index
for the North Korean serials
in the Library of Congress and
make that index available online
for researches and scholars.
It is not surprising that
more, more graduate students
and scholars are taking a
deep interest in North Korea
because they know they can find
a primary source information
on Korea-- North Korea at
the Library of Congress.
So let's give you one example.
For example, you are
looking for any article
or information education
in South Korea,
you go on over any database
like a ProQuest education.
You search the education
in South Korea.
There are over 13,000
search results.
Wait for manual research.
So you can modify your search
or you can use advanced search
and narrow down the results.
You may find the interesting
article and can request article
because of citation information.
But for the North
Korean serials,
that was not the
case in the past.
Now, [inaudible] database
let you study North Korea
in unusual depths.
Provide the range of benefits,
you can search, browse,
sort and narrow down the result.
Researchers can search
everything in database or limit
to search to article title
or subject or article query,
publication date and publisher.
All user can also
browse by author,
by subject and serial titles.
Selected article can be
accessed on site at the library.
Subject search, to search by
subject, you may enter any term
or phrase and choose limit
by search or subject.
Alternatively, you may
select browse by subject.
We try the subject
search with women
and we retrieved a
total 1,262 results.
You can sort by title,
name, date for all searches.
Specially dates, sort will be
really helpful in this case
at dealing with this
manual research.
Let's open the first
article, [foreign language].
So this record shows title
in Korean Romanized title,
publication information and
publisher and then citation
which is this article is
from [foreign language]
published 1949,
volume 10, page from 96-99.
From this point, you
can request article
with this citation information.
Browse Authors.
Since we don't know that many
North Korean authors name,
browse authors can be
very useful which has
over 21,800 names in Korean
and Romanized Korean form.
So we retrieved eight
articles on the name of Kim Il.
Kim Il was the one who
joined arms resistance
against the Japan
with Kim Il-sung.
Also, you can use
a Boolean operator.
Let's see few examples.
So we are looking for article
with economics as the subject
and published in 1958.
We retrieved 757 articles.
And this time, we like to
have article only related
to South Korea.
So we enter Economics AND, upper
case AND, and 1958, upper case
AND [foreign language].
We got 12 articles.
As you can see, you
can take advantage
of article advanced search
feature like other databases.
This is very exciting feature
for the North Korean serials
which was not expected
to do in the past.
Of course, if you have a time,
you can browse all
articles index.
Currently, we have
44,249 articles
because alternative title even
though we made those 34,000
articles, we have more titles.
Search by publication date.
You can search article from
particular year or years
by entering the years, limit
the search to publication date.
To search for article
in the range of years,
use a square bracket and upper
case TO you can also add the NOT
in upper case to skip the year.
So for example, I tried to
search the article published
from 1950 to 1953 but not 1952.
So I use a square
bracket, 1950, uppercase TO
and then add uppercase
NOT to skip the 1952.
Here are the 244
results from this search.
And again, you can sort
by title, name and date.
Also, you can search [foreign
language] poster painting,
anything you can think of
on the everything option.
So the study of North Korea
is gaining more popular lately
among scholars and graduate
students, this unique
and abundant resources
at the Library will
play a significant role
in supporting scholarship
in this field.
North Korean's serial
collection is one
of our popular collections.
So digitization of these
collections is the Library's top
priority in the future.
If you have any questions
or concern, let me know
or you can send it to me
through the Ask a Librarian.
And then this conclude
my presentation
but I displayed some
of the books
and serials from North Korea.
Please take a look
if you have time.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Eric Van Slander: Thank
you very much for coming here
and thank you for inviting me.
My talk is going to be a
little different than hers.
I'm not going to talk so
much about the records,
but more about the procedures
to gain access to the records.
As was mentioned in
the introduction,
my name is Eric Van Slander.
I work at the National Archives
at College Park, Maryland.
Has anyone been to
the National Archives?
OK. Good, two people,
three people, good.
Has anyone been to the
National Archives in DC?
Oh OK, great.
So yes. The records I'm going
to talk about today are held
in College Park, Maryland.
And what I'm going
to do today is first,
I'm going to give a
brief introduction on how
to conduct research with
the National Archives
in College Park.
Second, I'm going
to talk a little bit
about the captured Korean
records particularly how we got
them, what they contained,
and how they're arranged,
again, just very briefly.
And the third thing is a
procedural like about how
to actually request the
records that interest you.
Now, first of all,
who can access records
at the National Archives?
The short answer, anyone.
You don't need to be
an American citizen.
You don't need to
present credentials.
You don't need letters
of recommendations.
The only thing you would
need to do would be to show
up in person either at
our Archives I facility
or our Archives II facility.
And you would do this on a
weekday starting from 8:30 on.
And in order to register,
you would simply have
to produce a photo ID, meaning
like a driver's license,
your work ID, school
ID, that kind of thing.
You would then complete
a short form
where you provide your personal
information, your address,
telephone and a brief
description
of your research topic.
The third thing you would do
once you would get there would
be to view a computer-based
research orientation.
And basically, it's
just telling you how
to properly use archival
records,
how to safeguard these
records, the basic rules,
procedures and practices.
Before I go any further, does
anyone know the basic difference
between an archives
and a library?
OK. The basic difference
is libraries tend
to keep secondary source
published materials, archives,
for the most part, tend
to have primary documents.
And in the case of
the National Archives,
these are primary documents
produced by US government,
executive branch
agencies or in the case
of the captured Korean records,
records that were captured
by people employed by the
commander-in-chief, meaning,
the US Army in North Korea.
And after you've done the
research registration process,
the last thing you do is
sit for your photographs.
So dress up nicely
how we want to be
and that card is going
to be good for year.
There are no fees charged either
for registering as a researcher
and there are no fees for
the support that people
like myself was obliged to.
There are staff on
hand when you get there
but it's not a bad
idea to let us know
in advance before you come.
At the end of my presentation,
I'll have my contact
information up.
But also at the end, feel free
to stop and ask me for a card,
I would be more than
happy to help you.
As I said, our research hour--
room hours are Monday
to Friday, 8:45 to 5:45.
In the past, we had Saturday
hours, but due to budget issues,
we have eliminated those and
we're open Monday to Friday.
If you're in DC, probably
the easiest way to get
to our facility in College
Park which is right next
to the University of Maryland is
to take a free shuttle service.
And we have a free
shuttle that runs
between our Archives I
facility and Archives II.
For those of you who preferred
to drive, we have free parking,
but come early because
parking is a little limited.
Unlike some places, we have set
times for requesting records
at the National Archives
College Park.
There are three requests
times in the morning.
And one request-- and three
requests times in the afternoon.
So keep this in mind as
you're planning a day
of research at National
Archives.
This change will
probably tell you.
So get there as early
as you can.
Get registered.
And after you submit
your request for records,
it takes usually about an hour
for you to get your records.
So it can take, you know,
the better part of the half
of the day to really
get rolling.
And at each request
time, you can request
up to 16 boxes of records.
And I'll explain that one of
these boxes looks like later.
And if you want more
information about going research
at the National Archives,
there is a link to our website.
And it talks about what
you can bring with you,
what you can't bring with you
and these types of things.
OK. As I said, my main purpose
in being here is to tell you
about the Record Group 242,
National Archives Collection
of Foreign Seized Records
from the Korean War.
As you all know,
during the Korean War,
US forces moved rather quickly
up through the Korean Peninsula
up to the, up to the Yalu River.
During that time, tens
of thousands of pages
of documents were collected
at various cities
all along the way.
I think the bulk of what we
have was captured in the Capitol
in Pyongyang, but there are
also things captured in Seoul
and elsewhere along the way.
The documents in this large
collection span basically the
period 1921 to 1952 and it
cover numerous subjects.
But most of these
subjects are pertaining
to the Soviet Union
and North Korea.
In a-- these records consists
of a variety of types of things.
Everything from official
correspondence to office files,
personnel files, printed
materials, things like books,
periodicals, magazines,
newspapers,
both in various types,
photographs,
propaganda leaflets,
things like that.
OK. The great majority of the
records that were captured are
in either Russian, or in Korea.
But there are also some
materials in other languages
such as Bulgarian, Chinese,
Japanese, Polish, Hungarian.
Pretty much any type of printed
materials that would have been
on the Korean Peninsula at that
time could have gotten scooped
up by UN forces as they
had in North basically.
After these records
were captured,
the US Army quickly spearheaded
them off the Korean Peninsula
to Tokyo which is where the
Far East command Military
Intelligence division was.
So those records were kept.
This again, these tens
of thousands of pages
of records were kept in Tokyo
for basically spot intelligence,
what was going to be useful
for the actual fighting
that was going on at
that time in Korea.
And after that, they were
shipped by ship from Yokohama
to Alexandria, Virginia.
And once they arrived
in Alexandria, Virginia,
they were held for a bit longer
for more detailed analysis
by the Army and other
sort of CIA type agencies
for any intelligence that
might have been in there.
And then after the
intelligence agency is finish
with these records, in
1958 they were transferred
to the National Archives.
Now originally these records
were held at a facility
in Suitland, Maryland because
the building in Archives II
where I work had not
been constructed in 1958.
In the 1990s when my
building was built,
those records were
transferred out to us.
The records are hard to use.
Reason for that being
as James will attest is
that they are not
arranged by subject.
They are instead
arranged according
to the way they were
shipped, OK,
which makes it quite
challenging.
Now the army which makes things
difficult always attempted
to impose intellectual
control over the documents
because you these
tens of thousands
of pages documented,
what's in them.
A lot of people can't
even read the language.
But, you know, in an
attempt to get control of it,
they basically set
up these inventories
where the shipment number
or shipment advice would
have been indicated.
The original box number which
would have been like a big sort
of footlocker type box and
then the documents were simply
numbered 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
that kind of thing, OK.
And that's how the
documents are arranged.
These inventories that the army
created were later microfilmed
and actually came to
us with the records.
OK. So these badly
arranged records,
how do you request them?
You don't just want to
randomly start with box one
and start looking, not
a good use of your time.
You're all very busy people.
I know that.
The-- what you do, step one
is you come to College Park
and you go to the fourth floor
which is the microfilm
research room.
And that is where you will gain
access to the microfilm copies
of the shipping list that
the army had composed.
The microfilm publications
at the National Archives all
have numbers assigned to them.
In this case, it's
microfilm publication M1950
and has a really sexy title,
"Shipping Advice Lists
for Record Seized by US Military
Forces During the Korean War,
1950, 54", so.
But that's the firsts step to
getting access to the records.
OK. What I've done there in--
nice and green for you to
look at, this is a screen shot
from one of the microfilm lists.
And what I've done, I've circled
in red the important information
which allows you to
request the document
that you would like to see.
As you can see, the
shipping advice number
in this case is 2005.
That is the shipment number.
And then box one of the shipment
in box in item one within there.
And you can see that it
has information in English
about what the documents
being described are.
And just for the-- keeping it
simple, I circled the first one.
And this is a printed book,
a 486 page document in Korean
as you can see at the top that
was captured in Pyongyang.
Now, if you actually were
interested in that book,
then the next step would be--
OK, there are two ways to do it.
And unfortunately, the National
Archives Catalog is nowhere
nearly as nice and
well-organized, this Library
of Congress, full disclosure.
But hopefully, the
link will work.
What I've done is
found the catalog entry
for the records being described
in the microfilm
I just showed you.
As you can, yes, Korean language
publication, records captured
at Pyongyang, record group 242.
And then this is a long
list of sort of the records
in this collection of records.
OK. Now, this information
basically comes
from the microfilm which I just
showed you a shut of earlier.
Now, since you know
the number, you know,
the shipping advice gets us
into this particular entry
and we know that it's
box one, item one.
So if you scroll way down
to the bottom of the page,
you see list strings of boxes.
OK. See right here, the SA
number is the first thing.
And box one, item
one is going to be
in container or box number 36.
So this is how we would then
take it to the next step
and order the records.
I will show you how
to do that shortly.
And full disclosure, please
contact this before you try
to do this on your own.
This is not an easy thing to do.
OK. All right.
So I'll try to make
it easy though.
So now that you know the record
group number, the entry number
and not the original box that
were shipped from Korea number
but the box that NARA keeps
the records in box 36,
we can take it t the next step.
And also in addition to the
National Archives catalog,
there are actually
for use of researchers
to Korean language secondary
source reference books done
by Korean scholars
that also help you
to gain access to the records.
It's not for everything, but
they've selectively gone through
and sort of thematically
in certain subjects.
So that's also a
good thing to use.
I think James when
you were there,
did you have a chance to use--
>> James F. Person: Yeah.
>> Eric Van Slander: And
that's, that's a good--
And again, that's a
National Archives product,
that's a product done
by Korean scholars.
I think I lost my-- I'm back.
OK. OK. So now that we know
the original information,
the current information
in terms of the box entry,
the next step is to fill
out a reference service slip
or a pull slip as it's called.
And that is something that
would have information we saw
on the previous page.
And this is something
unfortunately,
unlike some places that
must be done in person
at the National Archives.
This is not something you
can do prior to going,
you need to do it in person.
And then once you fill out this
slip with our expert guidance,
then you submit that slip
to one of the staff members,
not at the microfilm section but
downstair on the second floor
where you would actually
request your records.
Now this is what a
reference service
or pull slip would look like.
The stuff I circled in red is
the information we've gleamed
from the catalogue page a
couple of pages earlier.
So again, this is something
your first time there,
don't worry we're not going
to let you on your own.
We will help you to do this
and request the records
that you would see.
OK. And at the end of this long
laborious process, hopefully,
yes, you will have a box, OK.
At the National Archives,
you are--
even if you're only after
one document or one file
or one book, you are
requesting the entire box.
And this is an actual box,
I went into the stock areas the
other day and took a picture
and this tells you that, yes,
this box contains record of 242,
the entry and the series of
the shipping advice numbers.
So, one of these boxes contains
approximately a thousand pages.
Again, you don't have
to look at everything,
you're more than welcome
to browse but, you know,
it is a pretty time
consuming thing.
And as I said previously, it
takes about an hour for your one
or 16 boxes, however,
many you choose to order.
OK. Now, you have your boxes,
you found your documents,
what next?
The next thing you can do, we
have self service photocopiers
which are also scanners.
You can either make photocopies
of the records, 25 cents a page.
Your research required
functions as a debit card.
You can deposit money
in that way.
If you bring your own USB drive,
you can plug it into our machine
but we'll still charge
you 25 cents to scan.
I don't make these rules but the
most popular option these days
are for people to bring
either their smartphone
or digital camera and you
can actually take pictures
of the records.
If you are taking a lot of
pictures, we can provide you
with the camera stands
so you can click,
click, click, click away.
That's something-- It's free
as long as it's non-flash.
You can bring a flatbed
scanner, some people like that
to get really nice flat images.
As long as it's sort
of pre-approved,
you can bring the
flatbed scanner.
But the link in how
to conduct research,
that will tell you what you
can and what you can't bring.
If you're unsure, let us know.
We'll say yes or no.
But basically, any
flatbed scanner
that does not have a
feeder on it is accepted.
If you're running out
of time and you want us
to make copies for
you, we'll do it.
Eighty cents a page, not cheap.
Very few people do this often.
And this is our break
even number, by the way,
we don't make a profit.
The next thing that people
actually do a little bit more
and if you go on to our website,
there are lists of researchers
for hire and they
will do research.
They're not in our employees.
These are private people who
just list their information
on here and you can
reach out to them.
Tell them what you're
trying to do
and then negotiate a
price, price of thing.
So that's the other
option that you can take.
OK. That's basically what I--
yes and now it's
time for question.
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah. Thank you for
bringing that up.
Actually I mentioned--
I'm about to mention that.
OK. On day one, you get there,
you start using your records.
5:45 is fast approaching,
they're flickering the lights.
OK. Yes, you can save
records until the next day.
Actually you can save--
you don't even have to
comeback the next day.
You can save them for
three days or even five
if you plead your case and say,
I really need five
days, type of a thing.
Yeah. So, you can definitely--
You don't have to rush
and finish on that day.
OK. Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
Oh, yes. Unless you have
problems with the North Koreans
and their copyright
laws, I don't know.
No, I mean-- only half jokingly.
Most of what we have
at the National Archives
has no copyright researches.
If there is a question, if it
was a secondary source that was
in something was
captured, it's basically
up to you to work that out.
But you don't need
permission from us.
The only thing we ask if you're
going to publish an image
of the document or something
else, photograph, whatever,
give a good citation because--
you know, which record group
it comes from, which entry,
which box because we have no
ability to go in and search
at the document or records.
So that's like on a daily basis,
we get emails with like a scan
of a document saying I want
a copy of the rest of this.
Where is it?
And we really, really, have
a hard time tracking that.
So yeah, the short answer
is there are no restrictions
but please cite the document in
terms of-- and on our website,
there's also sort
of a format on how
to properly sort our documents
and that kind of thing.
So, OK. I know we have
a Q&A period at the end,
so if you have other
questions, please feel free.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> James F. Person: All right.
Well good afternoon everyone.
I'm James Person, NCNK
member and faculty
at Johns Hopkins SAIS
here in Washington
where I teach the
Korean Studies classes.
I am, today, going to
talk about materials
from other countries
about North Korea.
You've heard about materials
of the North Koreans produce,
periodicals and primary
source documents but there--
while this provide great front
door access to North Korea
to learning about-- and Sonya
gave some examples of things
to learn about North
Korean society,
about North Korean
culture, history, politics.
We also have great backdoor
access to North Korea
through materials that
were produces by embassies
in Pyongyang, the North Korean
capital throughout the Cold
War era.
For about a decade, I oversaw--
a little over a decade,
I oversaw a project at Woodrow
Wilson Center that went into--
systematically went
into the archives
of North Korea's
former communist allies.
So some of the countries
that we were in were--
we were in the Russian
archives, Chinese,
the East German archives,
Polish, Hungarian, Bulgarian,
Mongolian, Czech archives
gathering materials that, again,
are produced in--
largely in North Korea
and then dispatched back
to Foreign Ministries.
You have among these materials,
records of conversations
between North Korean officials
and they're interlocutors
in North Korea including
for example, the ambassadors
and also you have working
level diplomats meeting
with North Korean officials.
So you have all, you know, many
different levels of meetings.
You have very high level
meetings between say Kim Il-sung
and the Soviet Ambassador.
And then you have-- I
never see councilor meeting
with somebody talking about the
quality of concrete being used
to form the foundation
of the newly built annex
to the Soviet Embassy,
something along those lines.
So you have many
levels of talks.
And records are kept for
all of these meetings.
You also have these diplomatic
cables that are being produced
in the embassies by
diplomats who are there
to really observe what's going
on in the country and then
to report about this and send
these detailed cables back
to their embassies describing
development in the country,
developments in their, yeah, in
North Korea's domestic situation
and as well as North Korea's
relations with their allies.
These are just the few-- I--
some documents I have sitting
on the house last night that
I snapped pictures of you have
for example a-- these are
soviet records from 1954.
You have for example a record of
conversation with the Ambassador
of North Korea or the
North Korean Ambassador
to the Soviet Union, a
guy called [inaudible].
And then you have a
soviet report on classes
and class warfare in the DPRK.
These are-- as you can--
well, this conversation here
with the Soviet or the
North Korean Ambassador
to Moscow should add
that we also have records
of conversations that took
place in other countries, so--
that involved North
Korean officials.
So it's not just the
conversations that occurred
in North Korea but for
example when a meeting occurred
with the North Korean
Ambassador in Moscow,
you would have a record of that.
If a delegation from
North Korea,
we travel to other countries,
then you'd also have
the full records
of those meetings included
in the files from the--
the files on North Korea
from these archives.
Some of the things we can
learn about North Korea
from these materials are--
we can learn a lot about North
Korea's foreign relations,
a lot about their
domestic politics,
about economic policies,
military developments and a lot
about North Korean society.
There were some limitations as
many of you I'm sure are aware.
The North Koreans were
not always open even
to their allies.
And there were times when
the North Koreans were
in conflict with their allies.
So, for example, on the
early 1960s, the relationship
between Moscow and Pyongyang
soured, and that meant also
that the relationship between
Pyongyang and most other central
and eastern European allies
that were closely allied
with the Soviets
also were not good.
So in times like this, you know,
the quality of reporting
could sometimes suffer
but these diplomats
that were based
in North Korea were
actually quite skilled
at gathering information and
would often compared notes.
And one former East
German Ambassador
to North Korea described it as
really picking up pebbles here
and there and then assembling
a mosaic by, you know,
getting together with, you
know, your friends and,
you know, comparing notes.
And you often find among
the records converse--
records of conversations
between other diplomats
that are stationed
in North Korea.
So for example, you
may have a large group.
You have regular meetings that
occurred between East German,
Russian, Czech, diplomats where
they would really share notes
on what they were experiencing
in the country and tried
to develop a better sense of
developments in the country.
And this is especially
helpful when the materials
that the North Koreans
themselves produced don't really
provide or send a lot
of light on developments
and political conflict for
example, say 1956 or 1967,
these are periods
of them working on.
You don't have a lot of
information about other
than these reports that
denounce the activities
of these individuals who
are eventually purged.
Well we get a better sense by
looking at the conversations
that these diplomats are
having and then their--
the cables that they're
producing,
what was actually going on and
what issue is-- were at stake.
Was it simply as the standard
narrative, a factional struggle
or were there principled
policy positions at stake.
These are things that we can
begin to understand by looking
at some of these materials.
So it's a lot of use to
them for the historian.
They-- Really these materials
force us to step back
and ask some basic questions,
basically epistemological
questions about how knowledge
about North Korea
was-- has been produced
and how we know what
we think we know.
And I'm using these to
really challenge a lot
of things we thought we knew
about North Korean history.
Things-- I mean is--
I mentioned factions.
I mean this notion that you
had after the Korean war,
this intense factional rivalry,
we had-- you had Soviet faction,
and Chinese faction the
Kim Il-sung's group.
And Kim Il-sung skillfully
played these factions off one
another until his
power was unassailable.
This is the standard narrative.
What we see if you really
interrogate these materials
though is that it
wasn't so simple.
You had, in fact, principled
policy positions at stake.
And this, these positions seem
to be the issue of contention
and not so much the
revolutionary background
of the individuals.
It was much more complex.
You have internationalism
versus nationalism.
You have issues of the
culture personality
versus collective leadership.
You have the consumer economy
versus the industrial economy.
And these, again, are the issues
that are really driving
political developments
after the Korean War not just
this notion of, you know,
endemic factionalism in
the Korean workers party
that we all know today.
So, a lot have used
these materials
to really getting a
better understanding
of North Korean history
and rethinking what
we believe we know
about North Korean history.
But they-- These materials
also help us understand North
Korea today.
But before I get into
that, let me just briefly--
can I go into where
you can get access
to a lot of these materials?
Well, as I said, for a
decade, I ran the project
at the Wilson Center that
gathered these materials.
One thing I'm quite proud
of is something I develop
called the Modern Korean History
Portal, which provides
multiple points
of access to the documents.
And you just go and
then Google and type
in Modern Korean History Portal.
And you have, you
know, your timeline
which just features different
developments in Korean history.
And you can actually get
direct access to some
of the relevant documents.
So, for example, you
know, here's, you know,
something from September 6,
1945, you have a Soviet report
on communism in Korea
from that period
that is directly
relevant connected
to the issue discussed there.
You also have featured
resources including essays.
It's not Wikipedia.
We're not just letting anyone
write this, but we've--
you know, when-- actually
commissioned essays
from professional
scholars of Korean history.
You also had biographies of key
figures in North Korean history.
And then you have curated
collections of documents.
And just, you know, just
click on conversations
with Kim Il-sung,
you have hundreds
and hundreds of conversations.
These records or memorandum
conversations that I was talking
about with Kim Il-sung going
from 1949 all the way
through, you see here, 1988.
It's really spanning this
guy's lifetime in leadership.
So a great resource.
I encourage you all to
access it again to work
with these materials really
challenge your thinking
about North Korean history.
But, there's also have
use to these materials
and really understanding
North Korea today.
And this requires, you know,
sort of a longer term, you know,
work with these documents
across, you know,
larger or a broader
period of time.
These materials they
also really achieve--
they really challenge received
wisdom on North Korea today.
They-- And if you do apply a
broader historical sensibility
then you can really begin to
identify, you know, patterns
and really more accurately
interpret
contemporary developments.
Let me just look at two
areas where I try to do this.
So, one thing that's emerged
from these documents, again,
if you-- when you really
interrogate the materials is
that we can challenge this idea
that China and North Korean are
as close as lips and teeth
as the expression goes.
This expression is
suggesting, of course,
the level of intimacy
among two states.
And that Beijing today
wields enormous influence
over Pyongyang.
What you can see
from the materials
and then I encourage you to
look through these conversations
with Kim Il-sung in particular,
you can see that, well,
this may not be the case that in
fact there is a profound sense
of mistrust in the relationship,
really going both ways.
But for the North Koreans,
one can see from the
conversations not just
with Kim Il-sung but with
many other I mentioned
that you have conversations
at various levels.
At all levels, you see people,
North Korean officials
describing this profound sense
of mistrust toward Beijing, this
sense that China is, at times,
overly interventionist
and not respectful
of Korean sovereignty.
And what's fascinating is
to look at conversations
with Kim Il-sung and to see how
over the years the list
of grievances grows.
So, in 1955, you
see him complaining
about the actions
of, for example,
[inaudible] during the Korean
War that person who was
in charge with the Chinese
people's volunteers.
His arrogance and
dealing with Kim Il-sung
and he also blames
[inaudible] for decisions--
battlefield decisions that
Kim felt ultimately caused
him victory.
A couple years later,
you see him adding on to
that list describing events
in 1956 where the Chinese
and the soviets directly
meddled in,
you know, in a party conflict.
You see then this list
growing and growing
and growing over the years.
So you have the cultural
revolutions.
You have eventually
even the criticism
of Kim Jong-Il's succession.
But it mixed clear that there
is a profound sense of mistrust.
And this really forces us to
question this understanding
that we have today that,
you know, basically the road
to Pyongyang starts in Beijing
and that we really need--
And then China, you know,
again wields enormous political
influence over North Korea.
Clearly, yes, they wield
enormous material leverage
but what we can learn from-- you
know, by through the application
of a broader historical
sensibility using these
documents, we can understand
that China does not
have the ability
to act will exercise
political influence
because of this really
tortured history.
Another area where--
again, we all--
you know, again the
received wisdom is
that the North Koreans
skillfully played the Soviets
and the Chinese off one
another throughout the Cold War
that there were these--
you know, Kim Il-sung was
this master manipulator.
And he was able to
extract maximum concessions
from the soviets
and the Chinese.
This I actually think is an
extension of this understanding
that we have about
factional rivalry
within the Korean workers party
where Kim skillfully played the
rival factions off one another
until his power was
unassailable.
And this, I would say, goes back
to Japanese colonial
era propaganda
of this essentialist narrative
of endemic factionalism.
But Kim Il-sung certainly
uses this
and labels his rivals
as factions.
But we have this
understanding that Kim was able
to play others off one
another and, again,
extract maximum concessions.
But when you really look at
when you break down the--
you know, if you look--
really examine his--
the relationship between the
soviets and the North Koreans
and the Chinese and the
north Koreans over the years,
you see that North Korea never
really has sufficient leverage
over either Moscow or Beijing to
really extract these concessions
that we all think that they got.
And in fact what they did
receive was often stuff
that the soviets themselves were
no longer even using or things
that the-- or the
Chinese couldn't--
weren't actually producing
things that were helpful
to the North Koreans or
at least at the level
that the North Koreans
had hoped.
Moreover when relations
were poor with the soviets,
for example, from '62 to
'64, it's a very short period
of time, they were so poor
that the North Koreans
had really no choice
but to move closer to
the Chinese, otherwise,
they would have been
completely isolated.
Likewise when relations
report with the Chinese,
this is during the culture
evolution, they were so poor.
I mean to the point where you
had armed clashes on the border.
You know, Chinese
troops marching
into North Korean territory.
Then, you know, North Korea
really didn't have any choice
but to warm up to the Soviets.
Again, they would have been
completely isolated had
they not.
The North Koreans were more
reactive than they were,
you know, the master
manipulators, you know,
sort of juggling all
these balls at one time.
And indeed by the '70s, by--
as the more extreme faces of the
Cultural Revolution subsided,
the North Koreans took
steps to really reduce
to the extent possible, the
influence of both Beijing
and Moscow on a trajectory
of political economic
and cultural developments.
This is something they
started early but really tried
to make the country
impervious to these influences
and maintains a policy of
equidistance, you know,
keeping both Moscow and
Beijing at arms length.
So we really need to
rethink this notion and then
by extension really try to,
you know, look at the ability
of north Korea today to
do what many believed
and playing Beijing and
Washington off one another.
Is it rather trying-- you
know, by this frequent,
with this frequent
trips to Beijing as he--
or to try new other not just
the Beijing but as Kim Jong-un,
again, trying to play the US
and Washington off one another
or is he-- or the Chinese
and the US off one another
or is he trying to make sure he
has all of his flanks covered.
So much to be learned
from these materials
to better understand North
Korean history and, again,
through the application of
a historical sensibility to,
you know, better
understand developments,
contemporary developments
to better frame contemporary
developments.
Happy to take questions or
during the Q&A to talk more
about the documents and to
point you in certain directions
if you-- you know,
on your research
with some of these documents.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Daniel Wertz: I like to thank
our three speakers for that--
their excellent presentations.
I think that North Korea's often
misrepresented in the media
as something of a black box
where there's no
information that gets out.
I think these people on this
room know that's clearly not
the case.
But getting access
to that information
on North Korea can sometimes
be a black box for scholars
who are starting out trying
to navigate the resources
that are available.
So I think it's really helpful
that we've got our three
speakers today giving some very
practical advice to people
trying to start doing research
on North Korea using these
different collections.
And with that, I'd like
to open it up to question
and answers from the audience.
And do we have microphone
for the audience?
No? I'll just reiterate
the questions with that.
OK.
>> James F. Person: Yeah.
They won't be captured.
>> Daniel Wertz: Yeah.
They won't be captured
on the recording.
So, I'll just summarize
the questions.
Yeah?
[ Inaudible ]
So, for people with
limited language skills,
how difficult is it to use
these different resources?
>> Eric Van Slander: You go.
>> James F. Person: Well--
So, for the materials from
former communist bloc archives,
a portion of those have been
translated into English.
And that's what you
see available
on this Modern Korean
History Portal.
But for every one
document, there are dozens,
dozens more that
are untranslated.
And it is-- that's one of the
problems is that getting access
to this without the
languages, you know,
is going to be hindrance
especially
with the Korean language
materials.
I mean the index, the
serial index, you would need
to have Korean to
know what it is
because there's no translation
of the articles titles,
for example.
>> Sonya Lee: Actually,
I can show you one data
of this [inaudible].
This is in the same thing
with the article index but--
-- if you go Asian Reading Room
homepage pretty much what you--
what I told you CDR database
North Korean CDR Database you
see here.
But then the one we have--
sorry, I mean it's really
my eyeglasses is not good.
So there's Korean
bibliography you see in there.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes, yes. So, this is the
one covered until 1995,
English material on Korea.
So, actually, I played out
all these, topical term index,
which is from the
table of content.
So rather than dealing
with the subject,
you can pull it related books.
Find the books easily.
So this is arranged.
So this is English material.
We-- if we go like Kim
Il-sung, for example--
So this should be
between here, right?
So this is the one you can find
written by him or about him.
And then if you go
any of their article--
the record and you can
go from on and on here.
You know, you can go
by subject or by author
or if you click the
term, extra term
and you can go further
from there.
So, this is the one way you
can search the English material
if you need it from Korea.
This is also primary
record too but in Korean.
I mean the-- about North Korea.
>> Eric Van Slander: As, I
showed in one of my slides
at least the inventory to
the record is in English.
Although it's very
laborious to go through it,
you can at least identify things
that are potentially relevant
and then maybe get
some help, you know,
to actually translate what
you found, another thing
which is actually separate from
the captured Korean records.
We do have very extensive
military intelligence reporting
and these are compiled
reports done
by US military intelligence
people during the Korean War
period and shortly thereafter
using Korean language sources
and sort of summarizing
them in English
for dissemination amongst
Americans who don't read Korean.
So that's another possibility.
So, for example, within the
Far East command records,
you will have these types
of things within the records
of the Eighth Army, which was
the army that still in Korea.
You'll find that kind of thing.
In some cases where
North Koreans
or Chinese soldiers
were captured,
the interrogations will
sometimes be summarized.
So these are ways
where you can--
even if your Korean is
not perfect, you know,
you could potentially
still do research
at the National Archives.
But the time is always
the challenge
because as I said before, it's
the-- it's really hard to go in
and find the specific documents.
But, there are ways to sort
of get around, you know,
your lack of language skills.
>> James F. Person: And to be
sure, if you are doing more
of it, you know, if you're
looking more at a political,
you know, diplomatic
developments,
US intelligence reports
are pretty good.
Not perhaps as good as
some of the, you know,
the Eastern Bloc materials and
they're present in North Korea
and reporting on what
they're observing,
but we had our way
of finding out.
And you should also note, the
British records are always
and that they're
very good resource.
The British National Archives,
which I have to say, I'm sorry,
a little easier to navigate.
>> Eric Van Slander:
It means job security.
>> Daniel Wertz: And to follow
up on that question for some
of the older North
Korean records, those,
especially from the
1940s and '50s,
how much hanja are Koreanized
Chinese characters you need
to know to be able to read
some of these records compared
to more contemporary
Korean documents?
>> Sonya Lee: Library Congress
collection not the many
Chinese characters.
>> James F. Person: The North
Koreans actually eliminated
hanja pretty early-- the you
know the Chinese characters
pretty early on, you know trying
to eliminate you know, you know,
again, cultural influences
from China.
I mean certainly by--
I mean while you look
at South Korean records
and you see Park Chung-hee
using-- I mean, you know,
you look at a document and it
could be almost 50% in hanja,
North Korean records by--
I mean, really by the
early '50s are almost--
it's completely gone.
>> Eric Van Slander: With the
caption records, of course,
depending on the
vintage of the records.
So the earlier stuff would have
more hanja than the later stuff.
>> Daniel Wertz: Ester?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Eric Van Slander: Sure.
>> Daniel Wertz: Yeah, that's
just for the recording,
to understand the current
condition of the documents,
the National Archives
and digitization.
>> Eric Van Slander: Well,
the physical condition of some
of the documents is quite
good-- are quite good.
Some on them because of--
for example, if it was very,
very poor quality newsprint or
things like that, probably not
as good, to my knowledge
there is no project
to digitize these
records at the time.
I do know that there
are-- on a daily basis,
Korean researchers
they're digitizing records.
They're not sort of teamed
up with the National Archives
to share those images with us,
but they are going somewhere.
>> Sonya Lee: They
[inaudible] Korea.
>> Eric Van Slander: Exactly.
I know for example the National
Library of Korea has people
who come and digitize things.
The National Institute of
Korean History has people who've
digitized things.
So there are sort of
non-National Archives efforts
out there to digitize things,
particularly since they are
so difficult to navigate.
But at this point,
yeah, we don't have--
I mean in actuality,
we have very,
very few of our records
digitized.
And the main reason for that
being is just the resources
required to do that, because
things that are not digitized,
you know, the process
of digitizing them is
just so labor intensive.
And once the records are
digitized then, of course,
they're only as good as the
metadata attached to them.
So how searchable would
they be and if they're
in foreign languages, you know,
typical OCR technology
probably doesn't work
on a hand written Korean letter.
These types of things.
There are certain
challenges, I think, to that.
But yeah, I wish, you know,
tomorrow that we would
be able to do that.
But I know there has been
interest in digitizing
at least portions of
them, but at this point,
yeah, we're not there yet.
Yeah.
>> James F. Person: If I
can just add, Eric mentioned
that National Institute of
Korean History [inaudible],
they actually have
published dozens of volumes
of curated collections
from the--
>> Eric Van Slander: And one
of the Korean language
volumes not--
nor are produced was
produced by them, so yeah.
>> Daniel Wertz: Paulie
[assumed spelling]?
[ Inaudible ]
So what's the role
for policymakers?
>> Sonya Lee: You answer.
>> James F. Person: No,
I don't have an answer.
I've been-- This is
something I've been struggling
with for years now, for
over a decade, you know,
trying to make these materials--
trying to get these materials
into the hands of the
people who, you know,
need a better understand,
for example, the relationship
between China and North Korea,
you know, so what I would,
and not every historian is going
to be willing to do this, but,
you know, I would actually
take excepts from three--
for example on sign
of DPRK relations.
There are three documents that
I would refer to, you know.
One is 73 conversation between
Kim Il-sung and [inaudible].
In 1977, East German
cable on the relationship
and 1986 between--
conversation between Kim Il-sung
and a Mongolian official.
The conversation with
[inaudible] is 13 pages.
I know that people in the policy
community would not waste their
time reading 13 pages
even though I think it's--
they would learn much from it.
So, you know, just kind
of extract the most
important parts of it.
And, you know, you cannot put
them in a brief report and try
to get that in their hands.
I've had the opportunity to
brief people just, you know,
across the street
here, members of--
it's actually senators
and member of the house.
And I don't know that they
actually look at them,
they'll listen to me as I'm
describing the contents, but,
you know, I don't know if they
take the time to read the two
or three page summary
and, you know,
extracts or excerpts rather.
But, you know, there's so
much that you could do.
You know, you can't compile
all of these rich, you know,
materials and do a
two-paragraph summary.
I mean you can, but, you know,
as a historian, of course,
I tend toward, you know,
I want to, you know,
give the full context, you know.
So there are challenges and--
but, you know, certainly
the material is there.
There are efforts to, you
know, curate collections
to make it more accessible to--
you know, and then to
compile these forts,
but one thing I find with North
Korea is that people are just--
you know, you have your
fixed ideas and, you know,
no matter how many documents
I waive in front of your face,
you're not going to
change your mind.
That's something that's
frustrating us, you know,
as a historian who's been
setting the country for,
you know, a long time now, and
who really understand that much
of what we think we know
is-- has been, you know,
needs to be reconsidered.
But, with North Korea, because
there is this perception,
you know, again, the black
box or there's, you know,
this notion that North Korea
is unknown and unknowable,
people just don't want
to challenge these--
you know, what they bring to
the table already, these notions
that they already have,
so frustrating but--
>> Sonya Lee: If I
say one-- may-- one--
things that Library
Congress as a CRS
which is Congressional
Researcher Service,
so the Congress, they don't
deal with us directly,
they are the one actually
send their assistant
and their CRS is the one
collect, you know, information
and report to the Congress.
So that's the one-- they are
the one we are dealing with.
So I cannot say [inaudible]
but they are the one.
Because even though I
emphasize 1940 to '60
or the '70 collection
because they are the one,
because it's hard to find
this, so we are getting a lot
of wager, so I focus on that but
still we're still getting a lot
of updated, you know,
current publication.
So they are the one who
come and search, you know,
with the skills and look at
the checking downloads Korean,
you know, newspapers and
articles and try to dig out,
you know, fact or information.
>> Eric Van Slander: Well, on
your topic, actually in terms
of the National Archives, I
think for most policymakers,
our stuff is a little old.
I mean frankly, well, they
captured Korean records,
for example, it's pretty much
the end of the Korean War is--
But I mean in actuality, it
takes at least about 30 years
for records to start
accessioning
from the government
agencies to us.
And then after the records
accession or transferred to us,
it takes even longer for the
records to be declassified.
So in reality what you would
be able to access, you know,
as a researcher, it could
easily be something that's 50
years old.
So unless the policymaker
is really keen on history,
which they probably should
be, but they're not obviously,
you know, and I think our
collections are probably not
super useful.
Another part of the
National Archives,
the Presidential Library System
might be a little more useful
in that way.
So, you know-- and, for example,
the papers of the
National Security Council,
those kind of things,
but, of course,
classification always
becomes an issue
with intelligence work product.
So keep that in mind
if you're coming
to the National Archives
wanting things from the 1980s,
probably not the
best place to be.
Yeah.
>> James F. Person:
Although the country files
at the Reagan Library
from 1980--
through 1984 were just
released on Korea.
>> Eric Van Slander: On the
issue of digitization, actually,
the presidential
libraries are much,
much better about digitizing
things than the main part
of the National Archive,
so yeah,
their websites are
actually quite good.
>> James F. Person: Well,
they're only-- it's only--
you can only see them in person.
But Simi Valley is
a lovely place.
I encourage you to go.
It's-- But these were just
like four weeks ago,
I think, [inaudible].
>> Daniel Wertz: Jonathan?
[ Inaudible ]
>> James F. Person: Sure.
So after the Korean War,
you had this debate within--
well, you had a discussion.
You had-- you know, it was a
very diverse party at that time,
you did have people
with different revolutionary
backgrounds, but-- and they--
you know, and you had some
that were more internationals
than more in-tuned with what was
happening in the socialist camp.
And after the death of Joseph
Stalin, you had a reorientation
of the Soviet economy toward
consumer goods, you know,
sort of the-- shifting from
the industrial economy to more,
you know, geared toward
improving the living standards
for the Soviet citizen.
This was then promoted
throughout the socialist camp
including to North Korea.
And in fact, these new Soviet
policies were reflected
in Soviet aid to North Korea.
We're only-- all but 3% of the
total amount of aid was given
as a blank check, everything
else was allocated for projects
that essentially-- that
would have, in some way,
improve the living standards
of the North Korean people.
Kim Il-sung, however,
was really trying
to eliminate colonial
error distortions
to the national economy.
It was determined
to make an economy
that was more internally
interdependent
and externally independent
wanting
to eliminate the potential for
future dependency relationships.
After the Korean War,
he saw that the--
they were utterly dependent
on the Soviets especially
for military and so, he--
and as the basis for
developing an economy
or developing military,
you needed to have an
industrial economy.
And so, Kim was focused on
general industrialization
but focusing on heavy industry.
Wanted to, again, to eliminate
these colonial-era distortions
where you had highly
developed extractive
and primary processing
industries, but no ability
to produce spare parts
and finished goods.
So you had then this-- you
had discussion in the party
over which path to take.
Do you follow the Soviet model
and improve living conditions?
And the more internationalist
member
of the Korean workers party
were supportive of this,
but Kim Il-sung was
very much focused
on eliminating future
dependency relations,
including with allies, the
Soviet Union and China.
And you have then this
discussion in the party turning
into a debate when you have a
famine in late '54, early '55.
And there's a lot of
criticism of Kim's policies
which are focused so much on--
despite the fact that Soviet
aid is not supporting his plans.
He is mobilizing indigenous
human immaterial resources
to try to push through
his goals.
But then you have this famine
that comes with the process
of collectivizing agriculture.
And this discussion
turns more into criticism
and there are unfavorable
comparisons being made
between Kim's policies and
the policies being implemented
in the Soviet Union to
improve living conditions.
And at that point, Kim Il-sung
begins to see this as a threat.
It's more-- He sees as a threat.
It was national security
imperatives
and as a challenge
to him personally.
He didn't see this
debate as something
that would necessarily
strengthen policy but he saw it
as a direct challenge.
And so, this is when he begins
this process of othering.
In focusing on the revolutionary
backgrounds of the people
who were more cosmopolitan
who were more internationalist
and were advancing or
promoting the adaption
of Soviet economic policies.
And at the same time, he
is promoting his own--
highlighting his own
revolutionary background
as the core of the Korean
revolutionary tradition.
So he's marginalizing those who
are criticizing his policies
and engineering their downfall.
But what-- I mean, we can see
a lot about this from a lot
of the Soviet reports after
'55 in particular, but you have
to also compare with-- you
have to look also to fill it
out a little bit
because it's not--
the level of reporting
immediately
after the Korean
War is not so great
because the embassies
were just rebuilding.
They were just moving
back to Pyongyang.
And so, for example, the Soviet
Embassy wasn't even rebuilt yet,
they were operating out
of temporary facilities.
They weren't-- the embassy
was not fully staffed,
there were other embassies.
So you have to look at
the available reports
and then come here to
the Library of Congress
and read North Korea's own
publication, the periodicals.
For example, I was just,
before you all arrived,
I was over there
looking at [inaudible],
which is the party's--
it's the-- [Inaudible].
Hmm? [Inaudible].
No, I'm describing what it is.
It's a journal that's produced
by the Central Committee.
So it's the party's
official journal.
And you can see actually--
in [inaudible], you can
actually see the saddle
of these debates occurring
in-- among top officials.
But they're very subtle.
I mean it's not-- you're not
going to see overt criticism
of Kim and of his
policies in these journals.
They're just sort of,
well, you know, you have--
on the one side,
you have, you know,
the industrial economy
is the basis
of an independent
national economy.
And after you have an
industrial North Korea,
then you can have
improved living conditions
and we will have an
independent military as well.
And then on the other side you
see sort of these discussions
that we're promoting
an improvement
of a living conditions, you
know, the people have suffered
over throughout the
colonial era and then from--
after the devastation
of the [inaudible] the
American Imperialist aggressors.
You know it's time
to really focus
on improving living
conditions for the people.
And so you see these subtle
discussions in these journals.
And then again when you compare
that then with what you have
from the Soviet records and East
German record, then, you know,
forward picture emerges.
If you people have really tried
to look at this period though
or if you contextualized
some of the developments
that occurred during this period
including Kim Il-sung's use
of the expression Juche,
this is something--
you'll have to wait
my book, yeah.
So, sorry, long answer.
>> Daniel Wertz: Ester
[assumed spelling]?
[ Inaudible ]
So how many contemporary
articles are still received
at the library for North Korea
and are there any
restrictions on them?
>> Sonya Lee: We have currently
48 North Korean titles we
receive regularly.
And we have a long paid really
comprehensive selection area
but because we are getting lot
of those Korean scholars
compared to South Korea.
Actually we don't have any
limitation or policy not
to acquire that because
any materials can be useful
and then they entitle
to use it freely.
So we're still getting a lot
of North Korean materials.
Even I try to-- I display
some children's book.
According to library
selection criteria,
we can acquire a children's book
when you have a research value
which North Korean childrens
who has a lot of research value,
because actually we
have a few scholars came
out just researching
children's books.
So, to me any North Korean
materials has a value on it
because still lot of
things we don't know.
So any items and even
I don't expect the area
that we are getting really
interesting a lot of scholars,
for example, these days
that invite the North
Korean committee and they're
like really first, I thought
there's a committee there but,
you know, really commixing
comedy and then crown,
you know, you never know.
So it's like a really
playground, you have to come in
and play around to
find out what we have.
>> Daniel Wertz: And a lot of--
Are these materials made
available to the public shortly
after the library receives them?
>> Sonya Lee: Yes.
But anything, you know, coming
to the library takes at least--
average of five or six
months to finish its logging
and then finish binding
some cases and then--
so it takes a while but still--
so if you look at the record,
for example, we have until--
[inaudible] 2017 December
and then I get occasion.
That means you don't
have after that,
of course [inaudible]
keep getting it.
>> Daniel Wertz: Yeah.
>> Sonya Lee: But still we
have only available like 2017
and we-- Yeah, so
it take some time.
>> Daniel Wertz: And for those
more contemporary records,
are there audiovisual materials
in North Korean movies,
music, et cetera?
Or does it tend to
be more textual?
>> Sonya Lee: The
Asian Division,
we collect the printing
material mostly.
>> Daniel Wertz: OK.
>> Sonya Lee: Because we
don't have any facility
to play the music or soundtrack.
I recommend a few titles
every year from North Korea
but this is not Asian
Division position, you know,
it's in the motion picture
in a special format.
So not really-- not
that many though.
>> James F. Person: There's-- By
the way, there's a great article
that came out by Andre Schmid.
I think it was in-- was it the
journal of Asian studies or--
just a couple of months
ago that describes work
with these materials at
the Library of Congress.
He's at University of Toronto.
He actually has a book
that's coming out, I think,
later this year or next
year, so probably next year.
But that really just uses these
materials to get it, you know,
everyday life in North Korea.
In fact, there have been a
number of works that have come
out in recent years, again,
Everyday Life in North Korea,
Susie Kim's book on '45
to '50, which uses a lot
of the materials at the Library
of Congress, I'm sorry, at NARA,
at the National Archives.
Harrison or Cheehyung
Harrison Kim at the University
of Hawaii has a book
coming out in October.
That is about Workers-- it's
called "Workers and Toilers",
that also uses a
lot of materials
from the caption
records, and I think a lot
from the LOC materials.
But this is also
looking everyday life
of the worker after--
but focuses particularly on
the post-Korean War period, OK.
>> Daniel Wertz: So it sounds
like you got a lot of book
to read after yours, James.
>> James F. Person: But
theirs is coming out first.
>> Daniel Wertz: So we'll
take one last question
from [inaudible]
and then wrap up.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Eric Van Slander: You
mean from our catalogue or?
[ Inaudible ]
In some cases, people
are starting
to crowd source things
for our website.
The question is how
to make it accessible.
You know, how would
somebody search bring it up?
But, yeah, I mean, there's
an ongoing effort to try
to have the public contribute
images in some cases, and then,
you know, if possible
if those records
that the translation comes from
are described in our catalogue
to actually have a
link to the digitized
and then the translated, I
mean, but it would depend
by no means an expert on that.
So-- but there's an
ongoing effort to--
well, actually the term they're
using is our citizen archivists.
And not only the
translating things that are
in foreign languages but
also transcribing things
that are maybe written
in difficult handwriting
and that kind of thing.
But if you go to our
website, you know,
you might find more
information on it.
But-- And my job as a
textual reference archivist,
meaning paper of records, yeah,
I'm not really involved
directly in that effort.
Yeah.
>> Daniel Wertz: All right.
Well, please join me
in thanking this panel
for their excellent
discussion today.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.